hello there fine GAD I'm done where the
slow mo guys a lot of people enjoyed our
samurai sword through the bottles video
very scientist flying in do satisfy and
then they said you should do fruit just
like a fruit ninja and I said that's
been done loads by loads of people and
then I thought but we've never done it
bit slow-mo on that business limb on it
let's do it I wonder if it'd be just as
easy to cut through the fruit as it was
the water bottles if it's gonna be
easier but will require more adaptive
swinging and also you might get hit by
fruit right so you're throwing the fruit
unless you want to serve them up
yourself week I'm gonna hit with our
oranges and stuff I okay I went to him
hard I'll just serve them up under on
you bear a pair all right let's get to
it
my selection of fruit yeah I got a big
bag of oranges just as easy practice
once two miles because they're soft and
explode everywhere in order to make
these shots a little bit more visually
appealing I'm gonna try and throw it was
that a pun appealing yeah yes that was
in order to make you more visually
appealing I'm gonna try and throw the
fruit to Dan and zoom the fence at the
same time so I'm gonna be throwing under
my focusing on now I don't have a follow
focus so I'm actually gonna have to
touch the lens so it's gonna be a little
bit shaky and rattly but if we can get
the sword coming in and the fruit coming
in as it's zooming in I think there'll
be a nice shot yeah so let's have it all
let's have the chopper kirari level if
we can all right start with apples start
with apples some apfel apfel's oven how
was that good what was good yeah you'll
see it sure
good one it stopped down a little so a
little bit more you and folk that's what
I need to do I need to put spin on it
spin yeah this looks really good what it
Bennett
another thing to each console girl I
chop the tiniest bit of that I on the
shoulder bone right like the bone bit I
could save that just cuz it was funny I
just wasn't expecting the extreme spin
you put on it what's he doing just like
a googly at me oh it's perfectly in
focus too weak you can see the moment
you give up on it in slo-mo and then it
just kind of pops on the handle on the
tear oh dear ever so sorry about that
shoot right where I just hold the blade
here and you lob at me
so it's gonna hold the blade hard so it
just goes either side of your head yeah
that would look at that look amazing but
there's no way I'm not gonna beam you in
the head with it maybe with like a
softer fruit like it tomorrow tomorrow
yeah all right let's try it God B you
should have wear goggles there what in
case I get tomato my I just don't give
you a black eye with a tomato with fruit
I'm not gonna throw it
you're not oh they're like beef tomatoes
yes like they're actually ironically
called
slicing Tomatoes tries to move the blade
and try to hold it so the blade doesn't
hit you in the head yeah okay you ready
I close my eyes yeah baby this is gonna
I'm gonna get you in the face okay
slightly to the left oh you're my left
sorry camera left hey get ready yep
Oh big Jesus didn't have to beat it out
bloody launched it it's gonna slice it
if you throw it softer than that Christ
[Music]
hmm welcome me over there I'm loving
this at you sorry big bloody ell oh let
me see that
it was so amazingly close to the blade
I told you the face oh yes I could be
closer yeah good lob though
absolutely headshot on that that I was
not doing thought hit me in the chin it
hit the blade though yeah
slightly I got tomato juice no I can see
angling the blade to cut it hit your
chin because you cut it oh oh hey my
head though god it's sliced it but it my
head oh maybe the blade needs to be
further oh oh it did separate it's like
the the asteroid did I we get it good
luck by the way kiss me but the
impressive twice in the thing ahead yeah
I think we've got enough yeah I don't
think we're gonna get that perfect shot
with without me hitting you like 10 more
times I just go back to what we're doing
me oh come on now Oh
Oh God all over the tripod I've watched
it split and eject juice everywhere
nope too low do I
do though oh yeah yeah
you
maybe tuck it in huh
I don't think is ready for that that's a
good there's a good half yeah very good
how much bang on yeah sweet ah felt like
a fruity little ninja you look like one
oh I like your concentration face two of
like oh shut up no everyone has one
everyone has a concentration face it's
true but all it does is mean you're
focused I had to because you're lobbing
oranges at my face I was like if I don't
hit this it's gonna be me in the head
look at all this mess - we're just stood
on the on the graveyard of this vision
do you want ants cuz that's how you get
ants it's how you get ants hopefully you
enjoyed that video feel free to follow
us on Twitter subscribe to the main
channel that's this one and we've got a
second channel where we just goof around
we do it on the main channel we do for
em on the main channel we've we just
goof around in general okay but there's
two places we could do it tell everyone
yeah see you next time